yeah it's a bit like the former US
Defense Secretary Donald Rumsfeld to say
there are known knowns known unknowns
and unknown unknowns and perhaps most
striking thing about the yellowhammer
documents is how little the government
still knows about the impact of a No
Deal breakfast and one of the only
things that the time of writing was oh
no known was brexit day October the 31st
but now of course thanks to Parliament's
intervention that no longer looks so
sure so that will go across into the
known unknowns
column they know that the public and
businesses won't be ready and that's
despite the fact we've seen figures
showing a big increase in businesses
being registered for trading status
largely thanks to the government handing
out these so-called e o RI numbers
that's up by 88,000 to 160,000 in total
they know that warehouse availability
will be a problem but not how much of a
problem though back in January the UK
warehousing Association said 75% of
warehouses had already reached capacity
they know supermarkets will stockpile
but will it be enough today three major
retailers told us they were worried
about a No Deal brexit and they're
preparing to stockpile from John Lewis
Tim Morrison's and Aidid the coop they
know medicines and drug supplies are
vulnerable to shortages but not how bad
the shortages could be they know
financial services and data sharing will
be affected but they have little sense
of how badly they know energy supplies
as long lists I know shouldn't be
disrupted but they don't know how much
prices will rise save that they will
that there'll be a knock-on economic and
political consequences and think they're
currently trying to recruit consultants
to help them answer that question you
get the idea the whole document is full
of known unknowns the real worry though
and one that doesn't feature in
yellowhammer
are the unknown unknowns the stuff that
nobody can predict